[Music]
extreme listening are two words that
don't usually go together but there is
no other way to describe what diacon
does she made a documentary called White
right meeting the enemy where she as a
Muslim woman goes and spends time with
white supremacists trying to understand
what makes them tick and the way she
gets through to them is by listening if
we all learn learn to listen like Dia it
is Absolut remarkable the breakthroughs
we will all be able to make this is a
bit of
optimism Dia I can't tell you what a
treat this is for me I saw your
documentary white right yeah when it
first came out oh wow it struck me so
hard how you were able to
explore that human beings are basically
human beings yeah what I loved about it
was you went for a dark subject and you
found light we should probably say for
people who haven't seen it you decided
to go and spend time with white
supremacists yes and you were actually I
won't say marching with but walking with
those white supremacists in
Charlottesville when all of that went
down yes yes which was insane I mean I
had no idea at the time when this white
supremacist group said we're going to
this rally it's going to be in this
place called Charlottesville and I was
like oh okay great CU i' had gone to
some of like the Clan rallies before
then and it would be like you know four
toothless people there and I was like
okay well it' be nine people at this one
yeah I'll come along fine great I just
get to spend more time with one of the
guys I was very interested in that's
fine and then of course early in the
morning I remember they all gathered in
this parking lot and it was so many
people and there were so many weapons
and there were so many military uniforms
and I'm of course the only non-white
person there and I've got a camera so
that's sort of two strikes against me
and I had people come up to me going you
know who the f are you and what are you
doing here and who are you with so yeah
great morning and then they get to the
actual parking lot that they were all
sort of getting themselves all ramped up
before they marched into Charlottesville
and there they had their Shields they
had the batons they had their weapons
and they're all chanting blood and soil
blood and soil and something about
starting the
deportations that that will happen soon
basically and I just remember just
feeling absolutely ter terrified walking
into the streets with these guys and
then of course you've got anti-racists
lining the streets shouting and
screaming and everybody's throwing stuff
and I got pepper sprayed and it was it
was all very very intense because the
violence broke out very quickly and of
course I'm looking at some of the
anti-ra is going in I'm with you don't
throw something I'm just filming but
going back to what you were saying
earlier in terms of finding light when I
think about the films that I make and
the topics that I I find myself drawn to
I've often wondered you know is there
something really messed up in my head
the fact that I'm drawn to such sort of
ugliness and ugly Behavior the Dark Side
of human beings but you know every film
that I do every dark subject that I
touch I'm always looking for the hope
I'm actually always looking for the
light I'm actually always looking for
the love I'm looking for the cracks
where some level of humanity might
reside so the whole entire process of
making the films is trying to understand
the darkness but in search of there's
got to be more there and there always is
I think that by very definition of Hope
and optimism it requires you going to
the tunnel it requires you going to the
dark to find the light in in this case
of this one film when you go looking at
White supremacists not to say aren't
they horrible people because we know
that we already know that we know their
behavior is a part we don't need a
documentary for that no no but to go and
say what is it that we don't understand
that we're not doing yeah and the thing
that I found absolutely Aston
in was that this one gift that you have
this one skill that you have of
listening that these white supremacists
weren't going to change their stripes by
being screamed at and yelled at if
anything they're going to dig in even
deeper or being told that they're
abhorent but rather that very Human
Experience of feeling heard all of a
sudden the narrative their narrative
started to unravel yeah and to watch
them
struggle with wanting to hate you
because of what they've been taught but
actually liking you and trusting you
because of how you make them feel heard
I was just an amazing thing to
watch and I think is so relevant to so
much of what we're going through today
yeah in this unbelievably polarized
nation that we're living in and the
failure of both sides is the failure to
listen yeah I agree people always talk
about Trump this and Trump that I get it
and I agree with it but the one thing
that Trump has done is that he has made
a segment of the
population feel heard feel as if they
matter somebody calls you deplorable and
somebody says you are forgotten no more
who do you think touches your heart who
do you think you will sign up with even
if everything else he stands for is
irrelevant and might even be against
your own needs and your own rights but
you just go that's it and when people
look at our societies and we look at our
politics and we look at all the
different challenges that we have in
some ways and I don't actually think
this is oversimplifying it it is just
about human relationships all of this is
about connection or a disconnect a
fracture between people all of this is
about people and the same way of
listening and same way of being there
with each other in those rooms that I
found myself with some of the these guys
is the same gestures that we would make
towards somebody in our own life but the
difference is we care about the person
in our own life because we've chosen to
be in a relationship with them but the
reality is we are all different kinds of
people sort of shoved together in all
all these communities and countries and
expected just to make it work and it
doesn't work like that it requires
effort even the relationships we want to
be in require effort and even
relationships we want to be in are
difficult and our relationships don't
want to be in it from time to time but
there is a commitment there that we're
going to get through this we're going to
make it work because we're in this
together so we will fix it we'll make it
but on a societal level we haven't done
that to each other we haven't made that
commitment to each other that it doesn't
matter whatever convulsions we might go
through as a society but we're going to
make it and our leaders certainly are
unable to articulate that for some
reason and instead are exploiting the
fractures between us but I think if we
don't find a way way to make this work
the alternative to dialogue is violence
and you're seeing it and you're going to
see it more so we have no choice in a
way where does that violence come from
is it just pent up
frustration do you get a sense of why it
came out in violence as opposed to civil
discourse or debate or uncomfortable
discussions what led it to violence is
it that these people are predisposed to
violence or did the opposing point of
view contribute in some way shape or
form to push them towards violence I
think it is pent up frustration but I
think violence is also easy having a
conversation and reflecting and being
willing to really be there with somebody
else is difficult because you might hear
things and feel things that you don't
want to feel and it's about the other
person but it's also about yourself when
you sit with each other you also learn
things about yourself you might not want
to face that's difficult so in some ways
I think it's easier to lash out in
violence in our societies I also feel
like men in particular have also been
sort of socialized and trained
to understand violence or aggression and
anger as sort of the only ways that
you're allowed to express any kind of
hurt any kind of suffering any kind of
Brokenness so I think for some men
that's just what you do and it's a
legitimate way of expressing whatever
feelings and fears that you have also I
think a lot of people feel that that's a
show of strength
that you know people who feel broken or
people who feel inadequate or people who
feel like they don't matter once you act
out in violence because I've also done
films about jihadis and I found the same
sort of traits with them is that the
brutality a lot of it came from wanting
to sort of mask their insecurities and
their inadequacies and their lack of
respect for themselves and not feeling
like they're good enough and not feeling
like they're even worthy of respect so
they'll sett for being feared because
being feared and being respected
sometimes that's a very similar feeling
it's a fine line yeah fuz fuzzy line at
the very minimum yeah and do we
contribute to the triggering of the
violence I do think that when there is
nothing but walls everywhere when
everyone is hardened everyone's heart is
hardened and there's no possibility
there's no space there's no Oxygen for
anything else then in a way it also
makes sense that that's the step that
people move towards because they go well
this is the only thing I have and this
is the only thing the other side also
expects from me there's such a great
irony in all of this isn't there because
both sides accuse the other of being
judgmental completely missing the fact
how much they judge yeah well you know
what's really interesting to me is with
very few exceptions in our minds
everyone's the good guy everyone's the
sort of hero in their own head and most
people who do awful things in their
minds don't think that they're doing
awful things they think they're actually
doing the right thing they actually
think they're doing the righteous thing
they are somehow defending something
that is under attack so they are on the
side of right not I'm the villain of the
story very few people do reside in that
too and and take great pleasure in it
but that's very few people do you
remember the movie in glorious bastards
yes I know the film I haven't seen it
unfortunately Kristoff vultz an Austrian
actor plays the head Nazi I mean he's
scar
good and he he goes on an interview on
David
Letterman and Letterman says to him how
were you able to play evil incarnate so
well what did you have to do to prepare
for that part and Kristoff volz doesn't
understand the question he says but he's
not evil oh my goodness yeah and
Letterman says but where inside yourself
did you have to go to be able to play
this character so effectively
and you see the two of them completely
not being able to understand each other
CU what Kristoff vultz did so well is he
played the character believing he was on
the side of right yeah because evil is
what the other person calls you yes no
one Nazis didn't think they were evil no
we thought that they were evil and what
made him so scary is he wasn't an actor
playing an evil guy he was an actor
pretending that he was on the side of
right and that's what made it horrific
to watch
wow and you should now go watch the film
I will I definitely that gives me
goosebumps yes and to your point evil is
a judgment yeah everyone thinks they're
on the side of good yeah empathetic
listening we don't have even go so far
as it to say empathy you don't have to
have empathy but empathetic
listening is to show up not accusing the
other person of being evil but rather to
try and understand where they're coming
from exct exactly and that was the whole
purpose of making the film was exactly
that I wanted to try and understand I
don't need to know what a Neo-Nazi
thinks I don't need to know what a
Clansman thinks we already know that
there's no news in that there's nothing
I can really grapple with in that so for
me it's more why do they think the
things that they do why do they do the
things that they do why do people behave
like this and feel the things that they
feel and and find it within them to
treat others like that so I wanted to
understand that I did an interview with
the BBC and I got so many death threats
from white supremacist because I
defended Multicultural societies and
that this is a fact and reality and this
is just what we're going to have to live
with and the interview went viral and I
ended up on various very violent racist
websites especially in the US and
actually the police ended up having to
be involved because of the BBC I sort of
laughed it off at the beginning going
this is just stupid I've had this before
from the Jihadi side and the threats are
the same that everything they're saying
is exactly the same just their little
icons are different and so I just
laughed it off and the police were like
no really you need to take this
seriously you know stay away from
Windows do this do that whatever and at
the moment I remember thinking so here
it is again so I can either be afraid
which I've been afraid of people like
this my whole life or I can try to do
something different which is try and
seek them out try and see if it's
possible to sit with them and can I
recognize their human and can they
recognize mine is that doable when you
sit in person and can I find a way of
understanding them as human beings
behind the rhetoric behind the chest
beating and the ideology and all of that
and behind the threats so that's what I
wanted to do and I also was quite
conscious about how I was wanting to for
these conversations to go I did not want
it to be I'll tell you all my politics
and all my views and I'll Pat myself on
the back for having all the correct
views use then you get to shout your
stuff and then we all sort of wipe our
hands and we all go off and I can get to
be the great anti-racist you get to be
the great Nazi and you get to sort of
speak to your audience and recruit more
people so I was very conscious of the
fact that I didn't want the conversation
to go there and I also didn't want them
to sort of set the table for how this
was going to go so I knew that they were
going to try to provoke me I knew that
they were going to try to make me afraid
and all of that and I was not going to
fall for it I'm not going to let them
push my buttons even if they did
and that I just wanted to listen I'm
just going to listen and I'm going to
wait until the human being starts coming
out and the very first Neo-Nazi that I
met with he's the leader of the National
Socialist movement is the largest and
one of the oldest Neo-Nazi organization
white supremacist organizations in
America and he said he's one of the
first people that actually agreed to
meet with me because most of them didn't
even want to meet with me and he said
look you come to this specific Motel you
get one hour and then you basically you
need to disappear and I said okay at
least he said yes so yes fine I show up
there and then of course I suddenly
start realizing this is going to happen
this guy is going to walk through these
doors what if he has weapons what if he
has people with him what if they rob us
and it's just me and one other person
that do all the filming I don't have
security or anything like that and he
comes in and he sits down and this is
the first guy that you see in the film
and we talk for five hours and at the
end of those five hours he's the one
that said we're going to this rally in
this place called Charlottesville and
you're welcome to join us and I remember
asking him I said look why did you let
me talk to you for longer first of all
and secondly why are you willing to
spend more time with me and he said look
I disagree with everything you say
everything you stand for and he said and
the and the world view and the picture
of the future that you're speaking about
he said I actively will continue to work
against that because I don't like it but
I respect your sincerity he said you are
very clearly very sincerely committed to
your view but he said I've never been
asked some of the questions that you've
asked and he said and I've never had a
conversation like this he said I've done
so many interviews and he gets to be the
big bad Nazi in all of those interviews
which are considered very successful
interviews for him and he said typically
they go two ways one is either I get to
sort of dominate the interviewer and and
so I win or the interviewer basically
puts me in a corner and so then I get to
continue with my Victim story so I win
either way I win and he said this went
somewhere else and he said nobody's been
willing to listen and no body's shared
with me how they feel he said I don't
quite know why but I would like to
continue talking and so we have spent a
lot of time since and this wasn't in the
film because it hadn't happened yet but
last year or was it earlier this year
lost all perspective of time but he's
left he has completely stepped away he
publicly speaks for a peace and the
opposite of what he used to
be I think the the hard thing for people
to reconcile with
your
strategy is it's unpredictable in time
yeah it's a process yes you know which
is we want results and we want results
now yeah you know we want black lives
matter we want police reform and we want
it now yeah and we want to completely
change the way cultures have evolved
over decades if not centuries now and
the reality is
violence is the only way to Force
something Revolution is the only way to
force something to happen immediately
but for the fact that there's always a
counterrevolution and it's incredibly
unpredictable and unstable and no
guarantee that whatever we change is
going to last yeah and so this process
of chipping away and
unraveling way more stable way more
sticky yeah but unpredictable in time
could take a year could take three years
could take five years yeah if we stick
stick with the process it's going to
work it's going to work yeah just don't
know how long and the fact that here we
have the head of a white supremacist the
oldest white supremacist organization in
the nation yes volunteering to step down
not because of public pressure not
because of Scandal not because of law no
but by choice happened over how many
years from when you first met him so it
would have been 3 years the very last
day I filmed with him I was stuck in a
car with him for n hours I went to meet
him in Detroit and then he drove from
Detroit to Charlottesville and after a
lot of time filming together we sort of
got to the point where he would tolerate
a lot of annoying poking from me and I
also realized that I can get away with
more and more and basically started
saying that I'm like an annoying little
sister for him and you know haha that's
fine and whatever and the very very last
day he goes to his car I was about to
pack up some of our equipment and I ran
over to him and I said look is it okay
to give you a hug and I want to thank
you and I really appre appreciate how
willing you've been to just speak and
listen and he said yeah and then he
hugged me and I said you know I'm sorry
for being an annoying little sister to
you and he says you have a brother now
and at that moment I knew and I couldn't
say this when the film came out because
he was still the leader of this thing
but I knew in that moment he's this
isn't going to last he's going to leave
he might leave in 10 years just like you
said he might leave in 10 years he might
leave in 10 days I don't know but he is
going to leave he cannot keep this up
and I also remember the morning after
Charlottesville he had a couple of young
people around him who were just so
horrible the things that they said and
they just so aggressive and awful awful
awful to you to to me and to other
people and I had it out with one of them
and Jeff was there and I remember
looking at him going why are you with
these people I said you know better than
this you're not like this I said you're
a decent person I said I know you
believe all kinds of garbage but I said
you're a decent person I know it I can
see
it why are you doing this why are you a
part of this uh and he never said
anything he just stood there with sort
of just you his jaw on the floor and
just couldn't say anything I was right
he couldn't keep breathing and being
part of that but you also appreciated
the stuckness yes which is I've spent so
many years building up a Persona
position a point of view a reputation
that to Simply say I'm out no there's a
process it's not unlike being in any
relationship where you're in a romantic
relationship with someone that you spent
a lot of time investing in that there's
lots of feelings they have feelings
towards you and you realize this is
untenable yeah and rarely do we just
wake up one morning and just break up
yeah depending on the the length of
relationships it can take months or
years to extricate ourselves from these
relationships because there's so much
there's common friends and there's
family and these decisions to completely
pull ourselves out of established
relationships are not simple and so when
the quote unquote opposition demands
extrication because we say so on our
timetable
yeah it fails to appreciate just the
humanity and the difficulty of this yeah
these guys that are part of these
violent groups and part of extremist
movements their entire sense of self
their identity their everything their
position in life everything is bound up
in that movement in that ideology part
of the trick of of extremist movements
and any kind of violent gangs is you are
separated from your family you are
separated from your sort of original
support system and community and so that
becomes your only Brotherhood it becomes
your everything like you say you know
your relationships are that your
identity is that I am this feared tough
leader all that stuff and then suddenly
what do you do and he still to this day
struggles and still you know him and I
are in touch with each other and before
he even came out he's like they're going
to kill me and they're going to kill me
on both sides and I was like look from
the other perspective which I can also
see you also cannot leave and expect
everything to be washed off you
instantly so I said you also have to
have patience and I know it's very
difficult and I know sometimes you're
tempted maybe it's easier just to go
back because at least I know that and he
he'll say things like I don't even know
what civilian life is like he said I've
been in this for so long I don't even
know and he said like I know nobody
outside I have no friends I have no
support outside imagine that imagine how
hard it is to do that and then you're
just getting slapped around from every
side your your former Brothers you know
want to now assassinate you because
you're a race traitor and then you've
got the left saying I don't believe you
once a Nazi always a Nazi punch a Nazi
you know all that whole thing but to him
I said I don't know what to tell you
except you're going to have to hang in
there and you have to do your time you
don't get to be forgiven in two seconds
either because the things that you did
the things that you inspired and what
you stood for has caused a lot of harm
and so just saying I'm done and now hug
me is not also a realistic expectation
you have to respect the hurt that you've
caused so now you do your time and I
said and look I'll try to be there for
you and others who can will try to be
there for you but you're going to have
to hang in there yeah some how and it's
easy to say that and it's devastatingly
difficult to be in his shoes because he
really has nothing and nobody this is
the irony of belonging yes which is we
all desperately seek to feel like we
belong to something and when we are for
whatever reason marginalized yeah we
still seek belonging exactly it's so so
true when I did a film about jihadis
people are so kind of confused and also
sort of bothered by me saying some of
this but I said look what what I've
learned from spending a couple of years
with these guys and and mind you I have
nothing in common with them I have no
sympathy for their cause there's no
excusing what any of them believe
whether it's a white supremacist or
that's not the point of trying to
understand is not to justify or excuse
these beliefs or even to sympathize with
it empathy is not the same as you know
sympathy it's just to try and understand
it so that we as the rest of society or
as individuals can be more effective in
doing something about it so when I spent
these you know several years with the
jihadis what I came to understand this
is when Isis was just kind of you know
getting really big around whenever it
was 2013 something like that 14 and
people were saying oh they're driven by
hate and oh my goodness and they're just
so evil and they're just these monsters
and my goodness and this word belonging
kept coming back also this warmth I said
to people that they're actually not
driven by hate they're actually driven
by love and I know that makes no sense
to people when we talk about you know
guys who go and behead journalists so I
get that but that's still the truth the
majority of them were driven by love
people who didn't have fathers who
didn't have love in their own homes who
were rejected by everybody rejected by
other brown people other black people
other white people by every by by women
by everybody and then they find this
group that says hey you're one of us
they put their arm around you and say
it's okay you're okay and I'm with you
and it's going to be okay and so the
Loyalty that's why the kind of grooming
process or the radicalization process
takes quite a while you know these
groups spent hundreds of hours on
recruiting just one kid how much time do
we spend with a kid that's struggling so
we're up against a pretty tough well
machined very human Centric bizarrely
movements how good must that make you
feel that somebody takes that much time
to talk to you and to try to understand
you and to try to be with you in your
difficulties and try to talk through
whatever struggles you're having in your
life so the sense of loyalty and love
that that builds between that recruit
and whoever his recruiter is is
unbreakable if that guy then asks this
young person to go blow themselves up or
to go do something many of them not all
of them but many of them go and do
horrible horrible things for the love of
that person and I would witnessed this I
had a very strange experience myself I
met with this young woman in the UK who
was having a very difficult time and I I
was just nice to her and I just listened
to her and was supportive to her
whenever I was able to she'd had a
horrible horrible horrible violent
upbringing and I remember we sat on this
train back to London at one point and I
told her this I said you know working on
this film you know these guys that build
this loyalty and then they go and they
do horrible things and whatever and they
do it for these kind of leaders and
whatever and and she looks me dead in
the in the face and she said I would do
that for you and I said what what and
she said I would I would go kill or be
killed for
you just because you shown me love just
because you've been nice to me just
because you were there for me when I
needed somebody you know and I remember
when I sat with the jihadis they would
say you know I've been discriminated
against I've been this I felt like this
I felt like an outsider I felt broken I
felt long long long laundry list and I
remember finding myself sitting there
going yeah me too wow yeah I I felt like
that I went through that I went through
wow okay and then I would always be left
with a question well what is it then if
all our experiences are pretty much the
same and then I'm a woman on top of it
so I've had to deal with all of that
stuff too what is it that makes me pick
up a camera and you pick up a gun what
is that what's the difference then and
the only difference that I can sort of
identify is who is it that shows up in
your life at your most broken at your
most vulnerable willing to listen
willing to be there for you who
recruited you is the difference exactly
exactly so is it somebody that wishes me
well and that wants me to flourish and
grow as a human being or is it somebody
who takes my pain and manipulates that
and winds that up towards their own
political game that's the difference we
have to point this out which is a big
difference and these organizations are
so good at this as you said their
survival has been built upon it yeah the
al-Qaeda recruiting magazine was called
Inspire yeah which is when these young
disaffected children in the slums of
Paris or wherever yeah are online
talking to somebody they think they're
talking to the same person but because
it's a machine it's a team of people who
are who are available at all hours of
the night to talk to this kid whenever
he or she is ready to talk in other
words it's not necessarily somebody who
really cares about not somebody who
cares no it's a machine of people who
are there trying to recruit me yes for
political gains yes if there's quote
unquote evil anywhere that is it it's at
the high levels of these organizations
where people with political motives know
exactly how to manipulate yes broken
people and when I say broken by the way
I mean all of us yes you know dis
disaffected disenchanted yes how to take
that emotion and it'll have a veneer of
I'm helping you but in reality you're
helping me helping me and you're just
Canon f for my battle and that's the
evil that is the evil and that is what I
learned too is that the recruiter versus
all these young kids that are being
recruited there's a huge difference you
know the recruiter is being very
conniving being very manipulative and
knows exactly what he's doing knows
exactly what he's doing and very
consciously I mean they actively
consciously pick people who are
struggling of course if there's one
commonality between both films or both
movements for me CU people seem to think
it's so different and it really it's
it's like I said earlier too it's the
same guy it's just a different window
dressing but it's the same guy different
slogans different flags it is that these
movements cynically and also brilliantly
fulfill basic human needs that we all
have but some of us have ways of
fulfilling that and finding ways to fill
those gaps and some of these kids just
don't how is it that they have the
patients to recruit for hundreds of
hours and for those who claim to care
about their fellow human beings seem not
to have the patience yeah to recruit
them back yeah or prevent them from ever
being recruited in the first place but
rather demand instant change first of
all is that a fair statement I think so
that's the gist of what I've walked away
with having done both films I actually
started out very pessimistic and didn't
really think it was going to get
anywhere but I was still going to try to
see if if I can understand any part of
this but I left both films hopeful very
optimistic and the reason for that was
understanding these sort of systems of
Recruitment and the fact that it is very
very human that it is about human needs
and filling those and the reason that
gives me hope is that we can do
something about I think primarily it has
to do with these recruiters they see
that they can gain from it these people
see the potential they have a lot to
gain I think we say a lot of things but
I don't think we truly believe that our
society gains and benefits from the
Brilliance and the creativity of these
people and what they really have to
offer so I think their Brokenness is
Justified in the sense that we don't
look at them we don't show up for them
when they truly need us when do these
kids matter when they do something
horrible and violent right did we care
about what drove them to that point were
we there
when he was suffering or struggling or
cutting himself or what we weren't there
so I think just because we say things
doesn't mean that we necessarily believe
it these guys don't say it they do it
because they know they stand to gain a
lot from this human resource so there
are two thoughts that strike me in your
idea there one is the unbelievable
discomfort of patience yeah the fact
that I have to be patient for something
that I find upsetting up harm or
actually upsets the fabric of a
functional society that I have to wait
is an unbelievably uncomfortable thought
and the uncertainty of the time
frame the other thing which I find
upsetting is
that though manipulative for political
gain these recruiters are finding those
who desperately seek belonging and
aren't just trying to help the person
they're actually giving them something
to belong to yes exactly what do we
offer them whereas the counter might
want to help them out of humanity quote
unquote yes but I got nothing for you to
join no exactly I mean I'll talk about
civilized society and blah blah blah but
I'm actually not inviting you to be a
part of anything exactly so so it's
actually only half a process and so
until we can offer someone an
alternative place to feel like they
belong and feel safe yes we're going to
lose exactly and they have to feel like
they belong in safe the one thing that I
also noticed with this entire spectrum
of young people is their sincerity in
really wanting to change the world in
really wanting to contribute in really
wanting not just to be a part of a
community but part of a community that
matters and accomplishes something and
yes I think the lack of patience is
astonishing on our part but I think I
always sort of say that you know we are
so good
at articulating what we are
against we're against Nazis we're
against jihadis we're against this we're
against that and very rarely do we
articulate what we're actually for and
that goes to the point that you're
saying what is it that we're actually
offering other than don't do this and
don't do that well what should you do
and Beyond something generic exactly and
there are spiritual needs there are
human needs emotional needs
connection how do we plug into that and
give our young people a way to
contribute and feel fulfilled and this
is not just young people this is all of
us when you look at all these groups
they offer belonging they offer a sense
of purpose they offer an identity and
something affirmative it's not just
being against it's also being for they
are only about what they're for pretty
much only about what they for that's the
difference this is another great irony
right it which is these extremist groups
that we find apparent are for something
yes but those of us who think we're on
the side of quote unquote good we're
against them against them so so again
they're setting the table actually not
us right because the white supremacist
their first sort of few lines of what
they think or or why they're Associated
to this isn't I hate all of you who are
different from me because again it's not
hate driven as much as it looks like it
is they are doing it because they are
preserving a way of life they are
preserving and supporting and working
for their people they are for that the
jihadis are working to protect and do
something about the suffering and
struggling Muslims in all different
lands but you realize you raise a very
uncomfortable observation here which is
we're sitting in a black lives matter
movement yeah of which a large part of
the definition is anti-racist it's
against but is it it's a question I'm
raising it is a question I am an
anti-racist is that for is that against
okay so I have spent a lot of time in
the last few months or especially since
the killing of George Floyd traveling
around America and especially actually
in Minneapolis bizarrely the sense that
I get from all the black lives matter
activist that I've spoken to and been
around is not what they're against it's
the impression I get and I suspect it is
why hopefully this time this movement is
going to make even more strides than it
has done in the past is that it is
articulating a picture of the future
that actually includes everybody it is
about dignity it is about equality it is
about recognizing the full Humanity of
everybody so to me from everything that
I've understood it is about unity and it
is about us coming together for
something that is better something that
is more just something that is for all
of us so to me that is something that is
for something not just against you know
language is a tricky thing yes and words
have power yeah and when we have the
words of anti or against it reinforces
the division rather than promoting the
solution yeah and I do think that that
is a trap that you know a lot of us fall
into when it comes to a wide variety of
issues that are very important but just
because we sort of miscommunicate the
actual essence of it and it's also why
every time I speak about extremism
whether it's the Jihadi end or the other
end or gang violence for that matter I
do try to keep it as clear and as human
as possible because that's actually
really all it is I find that academics
and people that research this and have
written hundreds of books about these
types of issues for far longer than I've
been around just over complicated and
make it something it's one of the
reasons why I wanted to make both films
is I wanted to get to the human beings
and not just stay sort of in these
abstract theories and these big big
words that makes you feel hopeless it
makes you feel there's nothing there to
be done and certainly nothing for you to
do in in that picture and to me that
takes all power all solution everything
away from all of this whereas we can
actually all do something about it I'm
reminded of a quote by James Carville
the Democratic operative who said the
difference between Republicans and
Democrats is Republicans want to win and
Democrats want to be
right wow yeah and I'm struck by the way
you talk about the gentleman who ran the
white supremacist organization talking
about it doesn't matter whether he's put
in a corner and had a microphone turned
off or whether he gets to dominate he
wins
he thinks about it in binary form yeah
right yeah whereas on the left it's I'm
going to prove to you that you're wrong
yeah yeah so he doesn't actually show up
to be right or wrong he shows up to win
exactly exactly which I find very
interesting whereas on the left they
show up to be right yeah and it's very
interesting how two people are going to
have now have a productive conversation
where one wants to win and one wants to
be right good luck with that yeah and
and both walk off with okay I got my
part we didn't really talk right I got
to State my points and my talking points
and you get to State your talking points
right and then we shake hands and we go
or we go off in a huff and we both go
back to our constituents and say did it
didn't I do great mission accomplished
did you see me exactly did you see the
points I scored exactly one scores
points and one makes points exactly
exactly and so what's accomplished
nothing Zippo you know you are one of
the best listeners in the
world I don't know okay for a Muslim
woman to go and spend time with jihadis
and white supremacists and listen yeah
it's not easy so tell us some of the
things that you've learned that we can
actually apply like how do I listen to
someone I have a visceral reaction to I
may have judgment and disgust and anger
how do I listen well you first have to
figure out why you're wanting to have
that encounter for me the reason I
listened the reason that was the choice
is I want to understand them so that we
can do better at countering them and
having fewer of them around right and we
can't do that until we can understand
what makes them actually tick so how you
listen is uncomfortable there's no two
ways about it if you're going to sit
with somebody that you have a viscerally
just a negative reaction to if you're
wanting to listen because you're trying
to understand what I would suggest is
the way it's been for me is I sit there
and I allow for people to finish I allow
for people to empty whatever the stuff
is and once they've emptied it's kind of
like a rag has been rung and finally
then you can go okay done now we can
really speak it takes time there's that
patience again yeah unfortunately
patience has to be a part of it I think
you have to know why you're doing it I
you just have to sit in your disc
Comfort I'm sorry it was ugly for me it
was very uncomfortable for me and
anytime I would start feeling frustrated
or annoyed or angry I would just have to
keep that in check because again if I
was to lash out I felt in my mind anyway
at the time that I'm going to hand them
what they're looking for they want me to
come off kind of Center they want me to
lose my balance and the minute I do that
it's back to them again they get to
Define how this is going to go
and then the understanding part we won't
get to that because we'll just get
frustrated and and and I've lost it I
think if we don't listen then we don't
understand what makes somebody tick we
don't understand what value they
actually can bring to you and what
learning they can actually bring to you
there's no reason somebody else is going
to listen to you if you're not willing
to listen first so I think in order to
build a relationship of trust and build
a relationship that's based on Dignity
and respect somebody has to make that
gesture first
and and it's most likely not going to
come from the Neo-Nazi first
right so somebody has to take that step
and that's called leadership yeah it's
not the one who's at the top of the
organization it's the one who goes first
yeah the one who goes first towards the
danger the one who does the
uncomfortable thing first but that's
also the person that that stands to gain
the most because the amount of insight
that you get from that the amount of
connection that you get from that and
the amount of value if you want to put
it in those terms that gain from that
and the trust and the Loyalty that you
build with somebody making people
feel like they matter making people feel
heard and seen and valued we all want
that it's not just Nazis or jihadis we
all want that everybody wants to be
treated with dignity and that's the one
thing that was conscious for me with all
of these guys is just because they
dehumanize me I'm not going to allow
them to put me in a corner where I feel
forced to dehumanize them or I feel
compelled to dehumanize them because if
I do that what's the difference and
what's the point it's very easy to
dehumanize them it's very satisfying to
also I'm right and just look at them and
listen to their horrible hor it feels
great but what's after that we have to
get to the solutions we have to coexist
we have to coexist even with people like
this
so how do we do that are those gestures
going to come from them or from
everybody else and I understand you know
right now a lot of people feel very
angry on all sides and very frustrated
and people have had enough but you're
going to have to have these
conversations going to have to listen
going to have to be there through the
discomfort you have to yeah otherwise we
don't get past it otherwi the the needle
just you know remains stuck here and the
anger is the indication of the beginning
not the end exactly and it will continue
to get more angry and it will continue
to get more violent the anger is the
start of something and now we have the
choice of where we want to go with it
exactly and you can actually diffuse the
anger fairly easily but you have to want
to and you have to sincerely want to and
that's hard so it should be one of the
sort of strategies that we apply towards
the challenges that we're faced with and
then there's all the other systemic
shifts that have to happen the political
lobbying that has to happen the
Grassroots organizing that has to happen
so there's a myriad of solutions that
have to be deployed in this current
environment and having dialogue and
listening is just one and engaging with
the other engaging with your enemy
that's one aspect of it then let's also
see what we can gather in terms of
information from those people who do go
out into the trenches and engage but you
learn about yourself I mean what to me
has been extraordinary about all of this
is that I thought I'm going to learn
about them but at the end of it I learn
more about myself actually and learn
more about what kind of human being do I
want to be here's some of the things
that I've learned from talking to you
one patience is a
yeah I mean like oh you know like
I have to keep doing this uncomfortable
thing do I have to just when will it end
I don't know I have to just keep doing
it you know it's like H you know yeah
anything worthwhile is difficult and
requires patience whether it's getting
healthy getting in shape you know it's a
lot of hard work and it's a lot of
patience and it's more about process yes
than it is about an event yes but you do
all these things because you want to and
because you actually care so you have to
care right and though there may be
events protests activism they're moments
they're parts of the process yes the
other thing that I find really fantastic
and astonishing is it's fine and good to
listen and offer empathy but it has to
be followed up with giving someone a
place to go yeah it's not enough to say
don't worry your life matters I have to
be willing to let you into my home I
have to give you a safe place to sleep
that belonging is not enough to help
someone build their self-confidence they
have to have a place to go yeah and
that's difficult
yes and it doesn't have to be a physical
place I assume or maybe it is
sometimes but no not really it's more
what do you replace that Gap with the
club it needs a new club exactly exactly
so what are you for so what do you sign
up to instead of that what takes that
place and there has to be and I've heard
this theme in all of the work that I've
done you pointed it love love is the
thing yes it's the only thing it's the
only thing it really is and the
empathetic listening is less about quote
unquote what makes them tick yeah but
it's trying to find out what they love
yeah because only love would make you
sacrifice parents sacrifice for their
children we would sacrifice our lives
for our children because we love them we
know that we fall in love because we now
find ourselves at the point where we
would willingly sacrifice our own
interests for the good of another human
being even in a romantic relationship
that we discover love when we discover
the willingness to sacrifice and I know
from my work with the military very few
if any folks in the armed service is
Rush towards the sound of a gun for God
and Country yeah it's person to the left
and person to the right and it's and
it's love even if they don't like them
it's love of the people to the left and
the people to the right that they're so
willing to sacrifice and then the honor
is bestowed that they helped Advance the
movement if that happens yeah and I find
this incredibly hard and such a a
worthwhile practice that for me to learn
true empathetic listening and you went
to the extremes which is why you're such
a good case study of what empathetic
listening looks like you know this is a
skill that we can we can use on a daily
basis with other people but if you've
learned to listen to a Jihadi or a white
supremacist or to toxic
masculinity yeah not putting aside any
of your own feelings or judgments that's
what I find so interesting you actually
are listening sometimes with judgment
yeah yeah but it's the sincere desire to
understand the thing they love and then
and as you described so beautifully
allow the towel to be rung allow the the
bucket to be emptied and only at the
point of the empty bucket when they've
had the chance to say it all now a
conversation can start yeah the
listening allows for the platform to
begin there can be no conversation until
there is listening first extreme
listening extreme listening and this
word love that you're saying I always
say that and most people roll their eyes
or shrug their shoulders a little bit
and go isn't that nice and mushy of you
to use that word and it's not nice and
mushy it's very
practical it's very fruitful it's very
strategic and it is at the center of
everything everything I know this for a
fact now I used to feel it and felt that
that would be true but I know it for a
fact I have sat with some of the worst
of the worst quote unquote people people
who have done horrific things convicted
terrorists all sorts of people and
really it all always comes back to love
and the second they sense any feeling
that even resembles that from you they
are willing to sit there in that
discomfort with you they are willing to
sit there and put their entire life in
your hands I mean I've sat with some of
these guys and some of the things that
they've shared with me and put in my
hands even I've sat there going
shouldn't tell me this you really
shouldn't tell me me this you know
because whatever I don't know I can't
include so don't they're like no I trust
you and so without love truly there is
nothing truly it's not hate it's love
did you learn in all of this to love
your enemy yes I mean I've become
friends with many of them I'm in touch
with many of them many of them will
probably stay with me till I take my
last breath or they do yeah I have
learned to do that one of them
was being kicked out of the University
that he went to because they found out
what he does and he also had the swastic
unsh the big gun and stuff like that and
I wrote to them and I said look you have
to give him a chance you cannot give up
on people he really needs to be in a
place of learning he really needs this
he's not going to shoot up the school
but he might if he's got nothing Les
left to live for we cannot give up on
each other we cannot give up on people
and most of these people have given up
on themselves most of these people have
given up on us and so I refuse to do
that I refuse to do it doesn't matter
how far gone somebody is doesn't matter
how ugly somebody's behavior is I will
try to stick it out for as long as I can
bear it because that's what's needed you
know and that's what we would need
that's what you and I would need when we
break that's what we need is that
somebody doesn't give up on us somebody
doesn't turn their back on us right
diakon you are an inspiration and as you
always do in all your work we entered a
dark place and came out to the light and
found the
light I'm so grateful thank you so so
much thank you I'm very grateful thank
you so
[Music]
much if you enjoyed this podcast and
you'd like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to
podcasts until then take care of
yourself take care of each
other